turning now overseas and Ukraine will
get western-made battle tanks for the
first time including American-made tanks
U.S is expected to announce as early as
today that it will send around 30 M1
Abrams Tanks you see him on the left
there and this morning Germany said it
will donate leopard chew tanks both
considered top of the line it's a major
policy reversal and a boost for
Ukraine's Defenders at a crucial time as
Deborah patta reports
a recent tank battle on the Eastern
front lines Ukrainian troops firing on
the move
Western tanks have long been at the top
of Keith's wish list
an armored fist to punch through Russian
lines and retake territory but there's
been extreme reluctance from some
Western allies to send those tanks with
Germany worried they could escalate the
wall then Following last week's meeting
of NATO allies a diplomatic breakthrough
the U.S has indicated it will send its
Abrams Tanks to Ukraine Paving the way
for Germany to follow suit with its
leopard two tanks for ukrainians
fighting on the freezing front lines
they can't come soon enough their armor
is no match for Russian tanks says
Bogdan of the 24th mechanized Brigade I
think Abrams is very good for us it's
helpful us for victory and on the bloody
battlefields of bakmut frustration from
soldiers like Andrei of the rapid
reaction Brigade we need weapons today
because after tomorrow this city can be
destroyed already but if we can't stop
Russian now
your army must stop Russian tomorrow
from the shoulder fight Javelin to the
missile defense systems and the U.S
supplied highmars Ukraine has used
Western weapons with deadly efficiency
throughout this war
and in places like Bahamut that battle
has moved into infantry War allowing
Russia to inch forward those tanks could
help Ukraine launch a decisive spring
offensive Nate
Deborah patta in Ukraine thank you